The following
content is provided
by MIT OpenCourseWare under
a Creative Commons license.
Additional information
about our license
and MIT OpenCourseWare
in general
is available at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So I hope,
in time, for you
to consider this
material also in thinking
about projects because there
are lots of experiments
to do with these.
I did a MATLAB experiment
that I'll mention.
And I guess it was
too small because it
didn't make multigrid
look as good as it is.
So can I remember the
steps of multigrid and then
you'll remember why
we take those steps
and then make a sort of
basic analysis of how
do you decide whether this
multiple step process is
successful?
How much does it
reduce the error?
So you remember the steps.
Oh, thanks.
So the first step is really a
little bit outside multigrid.
It uses an ordinary iteration,
like Jacobi, a few times
and-- so you remember
that the matrix that
governs this ordinary step, the
matrix that's crucial for this
is the-- so what multiplies
the error at every step.
So we have initial error
and if we take a smoothing
step with a preconditioner
P, then the error
is multiplied by I
minus being P inverse A.
So that's the matrix.
That's sort of the one-step, one
iteration matrix for ordinary
iteration where A
is our-- of course,
we're solving A*u equal b.
That's our problem.
The matrix P is close to A. Of
course if we took P equal to A
then the error would
be reduced to zero
right away because we would be
solving the system one shot.
But now, we're left with
some error and this-- steps
2, 3, 4 reduce it further.
And well, our hope is to see
that this multigrid operation
reduces the low-frequency
part because this one will
act successfully on the
high-frequency part,
the oscillating error,
but for smooth error
the eigenvalues here are too
close to 1 and it's too slow.
OK, so I was just
going to track down--
well, first have to remember,
what are the pieces here?
So there's a matrix
R, restriction matrix.
A matrix A_(2h), which
is original matrix A,
or A_h I could call that.
But the original one
is on the fine mesh.
So I need a coarse mesh version.
So that's what I solve on
the coarse mesh, the smaller
problem, and then interpolate
back with a matrix
I back to the fine mesh.
OK, so can I just
remember, also,
what those matrices-- we
have all the pieces here.
So if I remember what
R and I are-- OK,
so let me write down
all those pieces.
So A-- let me tell you the
MATLAB experiment I ran.
So A is our 2's and
minus 1's matrix,
out second difference matrix,
in 1D to keep it simple.
And it should be
divided by h squared.
Well, I guess we took the mesh
with-- where the coarse mesh
just had two interior points.
The value at the
boundaries was zero
and the fine mesh
has 5 interior--
so this will be 5 by 5.
Then we needed the restriction
and interpolation matrices.
So this was R, the restriction.
So the restriction, which
we're going to use right away,
will take us from the
fine to the coarse.
So that matrix will be--
it'll multiply things
with 5 components
and produce an output
with only 2
components, [INAUDIBLE]
near those mesh points.
And the numbers were 1, 2,
1, 0, 0, and 0, 0, 1, 2,
1, and needed to
divide by a fourth
because those rows
added up to 4.
The idea being that if
we restricted all ones
we should get all ones and we
need that 1/4 factor to do it.
And the interpolation
went the other way
and it was essentially
the transpose.
That's the nice
connection to have
and again, we need a
factor-- and maybe the factor
is 1/2 there.
Good.
We've now got all the pieces
except A_(2h) and I think just
at the very last minute last
time I said what A_(2h) should
be.
And the good choice
for A_(2h) is--
so that's on the coarse mesh.
So that's going to
be small matrix.
So the good choice is
I, which puts it up
on the fine mesh, A_h, which is
our operator on the fine mesh,
and then R that restricts back.
So R*A*I is the right
construction for-- it's sort
of the natural construction
for the coarse mesh operator.
And notice, I don't know if
you appreciate having this,
this is the same as R A R
transposed with some factor
so that it'll come
out symmetric,
it'll come out
positive definite,
and actually, it'll come
out-- in this example,
it will come out exactly
the second difference
operator on the coarse mesh.
So this will turn out to be
2, minus 1; minus 1, 2, the 2
by 2 operator.
And since we're on the coarse
mesh the step size is 2.
I won't do that multiplication,
but MATLAB confirmed it.
So that's where we were.
So I've sort of done
now a recap of multigrid
and I'm ready to tackle a
little understanding now
of what happens to the error.
So at this stage I end
up with some error.
u_h is not the exact answer.
I have an error e_h,
which is u minus u_h.
That's the error at the end.
Now the question is, what
happens to that error?
Can we see how and why it's
reduced as we do a v-cycle,
as we do a 2, 3, 4 cycle?
So since everything's
linear, that error
is multiplied by some
matrix and we just
have to track those steps,
see what that matrix is,
and look at its eigenvalues.
So that's my goal here, is to
find the matrix, call it S,
that takes a step, a
multigrid step, and what
does it do to the error?
OK, so can I just
follow that step?
Here's the key matrix.
Maybe I'll write it underneath.
So what happens to the error?
First of all, let me
write the steps down. e_h,
then, is u minus u_h.
That's-- entering
multigrid, that's my error.
OK, now I compute
this residual, r_h.
I want to say that it's A*e_h.
Can I check that that's true?
Yes.
A times this is A times u--
that's the b-- minus A_h
times u_h-- that's
the second term.
So that's OK.
So that's what happened there.
Then it got restricted.
I'll keep a record of
what happens to e_h.
So it's multiplied by
A to get the residual.
We work with the
residual and with b
because b is the input we know.
Then at this step two, that
residual is restricted by R.
Now we've got r_(2h).
When I multiplied
by R I got r_(2h).
OK, next step.
To get to E_(2h).
So what do I do there?
I multiply by the inverse.
I solve this system, so of
course, I don't actually
find an inverse matrix,
but that's the formula.
To get this, I multiply
the inverse matrix by that,
so I've got an
inverse matrix here.
So I write it as A_(2h) inverse.
This was A_h.
Now when I've multiplied by
A_(2h) inverse, I'm this far,
and the final step multiplies
that by I. So there you go.
It looks pretty
awkward, but that's
the matrix S that produces E_h.
So I'm thinking
that my matrix is
going to be called
S. This matrix here
is going to be called S. So
let me write down what S is.
All I want to do is remind us
what A_(2h) is by this choice
there, it's R*A*I. And then
comes R and then comes A.
A is now A_h.
Well, we've got a matrix.
And for this example, I
can compute what it is.
Can we say anything about
that matrix from its formula?
Looks a little messy.
But of course, it's built
out of these pieces.
It's built out of the given
matrix A and our R and our I.
And there is a neat
property hiding there.
Which you can see if
you square that matrix.
So look at S squared.
If we look at S squared--
so this is the matrix
to understand now.
And I don't claim to understand
it as well as I would like,
but-- so this is the matrix
for these three steps.
We would have a full
multigrid v-cycle--
just before I lose
the track on that.
A full multigrid v-cycle would
do M a few times, say twice.
Two smoothers, then
it would do a v-cycle
and then smooth again.
Well, I should've
said the smooth again
would be the one on the left.
This is the original,
so there's two smoothers
followed by a multigrid
cycle, followed
by a couple of smoothers.
That would be our
total overall matrix,
but I want to focus, for
right now, on this matrix S.
And I guess, I hope
that anybody who
does a project or a
homework on this topic,
you're going to create I,
R, and A and compute S.
And it should show
what S squared is.
So could I compute, could
I look at S squared?
You'll see why.
So I just write S down twice.
R*A*I inverse R*A,
so that's once.
Now repeat the whole thing.
I, R*A*I inverse R*A. I
have multiplied S by itself.
And what do you see?
Well it's nice.
If you look at this you see
that we've got this combination
R*A*I sitting in the middle
because when I did it twice,
the RA came from there and
then an I was at the start,
so this is-- so what's left?
S. This matrix S is
equal to its own square.
S squared equals
S. You know, we're
able to see this without-- this
would apply for this example,
but for all examples.
Now I'm ready to think about
eigenvalues a little bit.
What does that tell me
about the eigenvalues of S?
So this is a small class of
matrices with this property
that S squared
equals S. And maybe I
say something about those here.
So if S squared equals
S, what does that
tell us about eigenvalues
of that matrix?
It's a square matrix.
It doesn't happen
to be symmetric.
Very often we're looking
at symmetric matrices,
but this is a little lopsided.
We have an A off on the right.
I might be able to make
it symmetric by bringing
part of that A off to the left,
but this is the main point.
What are the possible
eigenvalues of that matrix, S?
Well, 0 and 1.
The only eigenvalues
are 0 and 1.
Why is that?
Because if S*e equals lambda*e--
so I'll put that word if in.
If S*e equals lambda*e, I could
multiply by S again so I would
get S squared e
equals lambda*S*e,
and that's lambda squared e.
I haven't done
anything fancy here,
all I'm saying is
that any matrix, if it
has an eigenvalue of lambda
and an eigenvector e,
then S squared has that same
eigenvector and its eigenvalue
is lambda squared.
But now, S squared is S.
So this is the same as S*e,
which is lambda*e.
You see that I now have
lambda equal lambda squared.
Sorry, I probably made that
take more time that it had to.
If S squared equals S then
lambda squared equals lambda.
So I have lambda
squared equal lambda
and the only two possibilities--
that's a quadratic equation
that's got two roots
and those are the roots.
If lambda squared equals
lambda then lambda could be 0
or it could be 1.
So what does that tell me?
That tells me that the
eigenvectors that have
eigenvalue 0, what happens
to those in multigrid?
They're killed.
An eigenvector with an
eigenvalue of 0 means that S*e
is 0.
So whatever error we
started with one cycle
through multigrid
will remove it.
These are in the
null space of S.
They're vectors that
S completely removes.
And these are vectors
where S*e equals e.
The eigenvalue is 1 and
multigrid does nothing.
Well, one part of
the message then
is that I could use
multigrid-- well,
I guess I hadn't
thought about this,
but one message is:
don't repeat 2, 3, 4.
That would be a
large waste of time.
If you just repeated-- if
you just did another v-cycle
and didn't do any smoothing
or anything in between,
then the error that came
out of the first v-cycle
would survive right through.
Nothing good would happen in
the second cycle that didn't
already happened in the first.
Now-- and another
message is, of course, I
could do multigrid
forever and I'm not
going to get convergence.
Actually, that's
sort of interesting
because we're totally
accustomed to working
with matrices M
whose eigenvalues
are spread out, but below 1.
This has its eigenvalues not
spread out at all, 0 or 1.
That's it.
I'd better say quickly that the
key matrix here is I minus S.
Just the way that it
was I minus P inverse A.
So the multigrid matrix-- yeah,
maybe I could've messed up.
The matrix is really I
minus S, so let me be sure
I see where that happens.
I guess I got down here
to figure out what E_h is
and then I didn't
do anything with it.
I forgot to write in the key
step that at the end of step 4
when I have the piece of the
error, then I add that to u_h.
So add u_h plus this
estimated error.
See, if I knew e_h, if I knew
small e_h-- the exact error--
then when I added I
would get u, the answer.
Of course, I don't know that.
What I know is
capital E. So that's
a cap E, which will agree
with e on some of these,
but not others.
So all right, I guess
I'm seeing the problem.
I may have headed in
reverse because it's
I minus S that's crucial.
So these are errors.
Now what happens to them?
Are these the good ones?
I think they're the good
ones, is that right?
They're the good ones because
the errors, in this stage,
multigrid gets them exactly,
so that when I add this in it's
right on target.
It's accounted for.
So these are ones
that multigrid fixes
because of course, everybody
recognizes that I minus--
let me just say it, though.
That I minus S times
those errors is zero.
So the eigenvectors
with eigenvalue 1
are the ones that are
perfectly captured--
E sub h has got those components
of small e_h exactly right;
when I add them on, perfection.
But then there were
other components
which it hasn't got at all.
And when I add those on,
no change, no improvement.
By the way, how many
eigenvalues-- so
these eigenvalues are repeated.
Like here, I've
got 5 by 5 matrix.
How many zeros
and how many ones?
You could say it's
a projection matrix.
S projects onto
these eigenvectors,
I minus S projects onto
and how many zeros and how many
ones for this, if A is 5 by 5?
Well, what is A?
This A is 2 by 2.
So if I look at my S, look
at my nifty formula for S,
do you see all this here?
Let's just get the sizes.
A is 5 by 5.
R is 2 by 5.
It shrinks us down to the coarse
mesh, where this is only 2
by 2, and this takes us back up.
So the total result, 5 by 2, 2
by 2, 2 by 5, 5 by 5 is 5 by 5.
But what's the rank of S?
Small prize for
telling me the rank.
I'm interested in this count.
How many vectors are killed?
How many go through unchanged
when I multiply by S?
So what's your guess
for the rank of S?
2, exactly.
So S will have 2 of these guys.
2.
This has multiplicity
2 in the 5 by 5 case
and this one has multiplicity 3.
So multigrid is only fixing
2-- getting 2 vectors
exactly right.
And not getting these right.
Well, I mean, 2 is half of 5.
Well, in fact, 2 is exactly
half of 5 because if I went up
it would be 3 and 7, 4 and 9.
The point is that the
number of coarse grid points
is about half the number
of fine grid points.
So 2 is about half
of 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
Of course, how could I expect
better than getting 2 perfect?
I can't expect more because the
problem I ultimately solve here
is on the 2 by 2 size.
So when I actually
do something useful,
I'm only doing it on the coarse
grid and that's got dimension 2
and so there will be 2
eigenvectors that get perfectly
fixed, but the others don't.
I do have to think, which
are the eigenvectors?
What eigenvectors are they?
I guess what I hope is,
what I believe is that these
eigenvectors, which multigrid
fixes for me, those e's-- well,
the es have 5 components.
Our matrix S is 5 by 5.
I guess I'm thinking,
I'm expecting
that the eigenvectors-- that
these two are somehow basically
on the coarse mesh.
And that these 3
that don't get fixed
are somehow basically
orthogonal to the coarse mesh,
I would say.
That these will be
low-frequency vectors and these
will be high-frequency vectors.
That's what I expect and
that's what somebody-- I mean,
there are whole
books on multigrid,
where the main step
in the analysis
is to see that those
eigenvectors are
as I described, sort of coarse
mesh vectors that are fixed
and fine mesh vectors that
don't get fixed by multigrid
and those are the ones that
a smoother better deal with.
I mentioned that just before
class I did a MATLAB experiment
and I actually did
it on these matrices
with a Jacobi smoother.
And I broke down the
numbers here somewhere.
And actually, I was a
little disappointed.
But I came away saying, OK, 5
by 5 just wasn't big enough.
So I'll put down what I've got.
What did I get for
the eigenvalues of S?
I got 1 and 0.
That was a good thing.
Now, did I write them down?
I sure hope I did.
Yep.
So the question is, what
about when M is in there?
So the exercises were find
the eigenvalues-- well,
it'd be interesting,
first of all,
to know the eigenvalues of M.
This is the Jacobi smoother,
weighted Jacobi.
Here's one we're
really interested in.
We're interested in
doing a smoother,
doing a multigrid cycle,
and doing a smoother.
I'm hoping that those
eigenvalues are below this.
So this is one smoother and
this is smoothers with multigrid
and this would be two smoothers
and two post-smoothers,
so repeating Jacobi twice.
And M cubed would
be interesting.
Here is what I got
for these things.
What do I know about
the eigenvalues of M?
Do you remember that we
actually worked those out?
For ordinary Jacobi
they're cosines
and for weighted Jacobi,
that weight omega, which I
chose to be 2/3, comes into it.
Anyway, so in a 5
by 5 case-- well,
it's the biggest one that
we all really want to know.
So this is the
maximum eigenvalue.
Let me just write
down the maximum.
So the maximum
eigenvalue of M was 0.91.
So that says that ordinary
Jacobi on a 5 by 5 problem
reduces the error by that
factor at every step.
And of course that factor
is totally satisfactory.
If we could always do that we
wouldn't need to do multigrid.
But that 0.91, if I go
to 7 by 7 or 9 by 9,
it's going to quickly
move up toward 1.
That's an indication that
my little experiment here
is a bit small because
that's not as near 1
as a true thing would.
OK, what was the
result after this?
I'm sorry to say
that it was 0.88.
Disappointing.
So I did this one.
I did 2 smoothers.
Well, of course that's going to
give me 0.91 squared in there.
But anyway, I got 0.64.
Which, of course, is very good.
I'll say very good, but
actually for that size,
I had hoped for better, because
my impression of multigrid,
from reading about
it, is that-- I
mean that a good
multigrid cycle, but this
has an eigenvalue of
about 0.1, is the goal.
So how is that achieved?
Well, I don't want to
achieve it by just doing
a whole lot more smoothing.
Actually it's achieved by doing
a whole lot more multigrid.
Instead of doing just
a little v-cycle,
this would be the same for
a good, deep V-cycle that
went down maybe 4 and maybe
a W-cycle, do it twice.
Then-- of course, this
is for a big problem,
but really making multigrid
work, like a W-cycle.
Or even there's something
called full multigrid.
Should I draw the
picture that corresponds
to W for full multigrid?
So full multigrid, you
start on a coarse mesh.
Go up, back; up, up,
back, back, maybe twice;
up, up, up to this level,
back, back, back, and up again.
So that's called full multigrid.
That gives the best numbers.
Anyway, we get numbers like
this for when we really do more
and it's very much worth it.
I mean, it's
completely a success.
I would be interested to
see a little-- well, I
guess what I'm going to do
now is, for this model problem
that we worked on, I could
find these eigenvectors, e.
And analyze this model problem.
OK, so how to find
these eigenvectors.
Again, for these
particular matrices.
Well, let me start with the
eigenvectors of A itself.
Do we know the
eigenvectors of A?
I guess if I had one
important matrix, whose
eigenvectors-- and nontrivial.
I can't look at the 5
by 5 there and guess--
you know, at sight say
what the eigenvectors are.
So everybody sees it's 5 by
5 with four minus 1's below,
five 2's on the diagonal, four
minus 1's above the diagonal,
and the eigenvectors of
those special matrices
have a special form, which
allows us to do everything
here.
So what can I do here?
I can do the computation
of what S is.
Can I report on that,
which will be in the notes.
Let me tell you what S is.
If I take that as a R,
that as I, that as A_(2h),
I get S to be this matrix.
Column of 0's; 1/2, 1, 1/2;
column of 0's; 1/2, 1, 1/2;
and column of 0's.
So it's rather remarkable
in this particular case.
Now what can we
recognize from this?
Well, can we see eigenvalues of
S explicitly from the matrix?
Well, we certainly see
that it has rank 2.
It has 2 independent columns so
its rank is 2 as we predicted.
So it will have three
zero eigenvalues,
and we can see what the
eigenvectors are actually.
What are the eigenvectors--
if I go up above here?
Can I do that?
I want to go up
and say something
about the eigenvectors
with eigenvalue zero.
What's the null
space of that matrix?
If I multiple S by vectors,
I want to get zero vectors.
The eigenvectors e for
lambda equals zero,
if I multiply by anything
with a first component,
nothing in the-- with
these three components,
you see that if I multiply--
S*e is zero there for these e's.
In a way that's exactly
what I hoped for.
That these vectors
e are the vectors
that live on the fine
grid, but with no component
on the coarse grid.
And they're the ones which have
S*e equal zero and multigrid
doesn't help.
Multigrid doesn't help.
I minus S times those vectors is
those vectors, no improvement.
So they're eigenvectors
with eigenvalue 0 for S,
but with 1 for I minus S.
See, my general thought
is those would be the
high-frequency vectors.
They're sort of high frequency,
but they're not low frequency
anyway.
Because low frequency, these
would be a smooth vector.
OK, so what are the eigenvectors
with-- the other two
eigenvectors, the ones
that multigrid fixes?
OK, so I'm looking for the
other two eigenvectors here.
And how do I find them?
Let me see if I can even
do it for this matrix.
I'm looking for the eigenvectors
with eigenvalue 1 now.
So I should subtract the
identity from this matrix.
When I subtract the
identity the ones
become zeros and the
zeros become minus ones.
That's S minus I now, trying to
keep a running equation that's
correct.
That's S minus I.
And I'm looking
for the null space of that now.
Am I going to find it?
I don't know.
Do you see immediately
what-- that has
a two-dimensional null space.
There are two vectors and
can you see what they are?
What do you think?
Yeah, we certainly could.
I don't know
whether-- anybody see
a vector that's in the
null space of that matrix?
Let me just start
and try to get one.
So I'm looking at
that matrix, looking
for a vector in its null space.
And that will be an error vector
that multigrid totally fixes.
Say if I start with a 1 up
in that first component then
the first row will force
me to have a 2 there.
Is that right?
And then I fixed the
first row, the second row
is all zeros already.
Then I have 0.5 of
that, which is 1.
Oh, let me start
from the bottom here.
Well, it's probably symmetric.
What do you think?
Maybe something like 1, 2,
and what's that middle number?
Maybe 2.
I think that that is in the
null space of S minus I,
because if I multiply by the
first row I get minus 1 plus 1,
and the third row gives
me 1 minus 2 plus 1,
and the last-- yes, so
that's one of them anyway.
And the point about it
is it's pretty smooth.
That's what I anticipate,
vectors that are smooth,
that's the type of vectors we're
going to find multigrid fixing.
So I've got one more
eigenvector to find.
Maybe I'll leave
that as a puzzle.
Somerville there's
another eigenvector.
Guess I'm not sure
where it is, but I
think it should be smooth.
Somewhere there is one.
Can I now go away from
this numerical example
to give you the answer for
this problem, but for any size?
Oh, it's because we know
the eigenvectors of A.
I started to talk about
the eigenvectors of A
and I didn't finish.
If I want to get
formulas for these
I need to know the
eigenvectors of A. So A,
this matrix of 2's and
minus 1's, the eigenvectors
of that matrix are
discrete sine functions.
So an eigenvector would be
for example, sine of pi on 6,
sine of 2*pi on 6 up
to sine of 5*pi on 6.
It's worth knowing that
those are eigenvectors.
And other eigenvectors
would double the frequency,
triple the frequency, four times
the frequency and five times.
The eigenvectors of
this matrix are what
I will call discrete sines.
Discrete sine vectors.
And why?
Because this matrix builds
in the boundary condition
since there should be a minus
1 there, but it's chopped off.
That minus 1, if
it was there would
multiply the zeroth component.
But the zeroth
component is removed,
so we have to be sure that
the zeroth component would
have been zero anyway.
And that's the point.
You see, if I
follow this pattern,
the zeroth component that I'm
missing would be sine of zero.
The component I'm missing up
here would be sine of 0*pi over
6, which is zero.
And the component that's missing
down at this boundary would be
sine 6*pi over 6, which
is sine pi, which is zero.
That choice of vectors is
the perfect Fourier vector.
I expect Fourier when I
see constant coefficients
there with the right boundary
conditions, zero at both ends.
Anyway, those are
the eigenvectors.
The k-th eigenvector will
have sine k*pi, sine k*2*pi,
down to sine k*5*pi, all over 6.
And I'll just, in
the remaining moment,
write down the result of
following through those vectors
and finding, finally, the
eigenvectors of S itself.
So this is like multigrid in
a nutshell, if I can find it.
Multigrid in a nutshell.
All right, better be
on this final board.
I minus S times
this sine vector ,
the k-th sine vector
that I wrote over there,
and I minus S times the
minus k-th sine vector.
So these will be low
frequencies, for small k,
and these will be
high frequencies.
And it turns out
that these are 1/2,
1 minus the cosine of k*pi over
6, or N plus 1 times y_k plus--
s_k, sorry.
s_k plus s_(N-k).
And this, acting on
the high frequencies,
is 1/2 of 1 plus cosine k*pi
over 6, s_k plus s_(N-k).
What am I seeing there?
Let's just accept the algebra
that went into this and see,
does that tell me what the
eigenvectors of I minus S are?
Because that's my goal.
Well, it does.
Look, if I add these two
equations-- let me look
first just at this equation.
So this says that if I
start with a low frequency,
k small, low value of k,
that it's nearly removed.
If k is very small the cosine
of k*pi over 6 is somewhere near
1.
Of course, 6 was
a little feeble,
so let me take N;
bigger matrices.
Then the low
frequencies are the ones
where this cosine is near 1.
This number is near zero and
they're practically removed.
Where the high
frequencies, not much
happens, because the cosine is
near 1, this number in near 2.
I divide by 2 and it's near 1.
So the overall picture is right.
Now to pin it down, if I
add that two equations,
then I get this combination
s_k plus s_(N-k).
Oh in fact, I guess I see it.
What happens if I add
the two equations?
I get I minus S times
s_k plus s_(n-k),
and what do I have on
the right-hand side?
Well, 1.
These add to 1.
So I get s_k plus s_(N-k).
Those are the eigenvectors of
I minus S with eigenvalue 1.
They're the ones I found here.
They're the eigenvalues
of S with eigenvalue zero.
These are the s_k's
plus s_(n-k)'s.
And they live completely
on the mesh points
that are in the fine,
but not the coarse mesh.
And then if I play
around one more step,
I can find the eigenvectors
for the other eigenvalue.
The ones that are basically
low frequency and where
we have a numerical example.
OK, I've run out of
time before I can
do that last bit of algebra.
That will be in the notes, which
we'll get onto the website,
Monday at the latest.
So I hope you have a sort of
picture of what multigrid does
and the experiments that you
might do to check it out.
OK, I'll see you Monday and
we'll take a little more time
to discuss projects because
we'll have material on the web
to work with.
OK, thanks.